We in the midst of,
uh,
laughs,
attempted to look at the seventh century last time as a turning point in the
history of the period that we're dealing with the post Roman world.
The early Middle Ages certainly,
uh,
among of a major shifts was the rise of Islam and the consequent radical changes
in the Mediterranean,
territory's particularly of course P areas conquered from the eastern Roman
empire by Byzantium,
namely Syria,
Palestine,
Egypt,
uh,
and eventually North Africa.
The seventh century therefore changed the shape of the Byzantine Empire.
And so it's orientation as well as culture.
Here I have a kind of periodization
we've spoken about just any ends expansion.
Very shortly after his death there begins what seems in retrospect,
at least in part to be a reaction to imperial overreach.
Imperial overreach is a phenomenon seen,
uh,
throughout history described most memorably,
perhaps by our own Paul Kennedy.
The tendency for empires simply in order to protect themselves or order to fill,
fulfill their ambitions,
to get too large for their own ability to hold onto their possessions.
This is an economic problem,
a logistical problem of resource problem.
And even a cultural problem.
Uh,
in general,
it's hard to say what provokes the crisis that is with the Roman empire.
As we're the opposite,
we can say,
oh,
well it was too big.
On the other hand,
it was too big and did just fine for centuries in the case the opposite empire,
maybe not centuries,
but 150 years,
which is these things go is a pretty long time here.
However,
we're talking about something that is much more obviously related to some kind
of overreach.
Justinian formed his,
uh,
expanded empire,
which is the first map in the handout.
Uh,
and merely a few years after his death,
it started to unravel.
You'll recall that we said that he had at great cost conquered Italy after the
easy conquest of North Africa.
Uh,
this,
uh,
looked like it would be easy as well.
But in fact,
while North Africa occupied by the vandals fell within a year two,
uh,
Italy took 20 years to rest from the Ostrogoths and the,
peninsula was devastated and,
uh,
Ian,
a radical economic decline when Byzantium took over a mere three years after
Justinian's death.
And five 68,
Italy was invaded by yet another barbarian tribe.
The lombards,
the lombards did not take over all of it.
The Byzantine Empire,
the eastern Roman Empire managed to hand hold onto Sicily much of southern
Italy,
the,
um,
east coast,
particularly the Capitol of the Byzantine province,
uh,
Ravenna,
but nevertheless,
the lombards occupied most of the peninsula.
And,
uh,
as we'll discuss in a moment,
other disasters piled up in this period that I have just called contraction.
But it's not just a question of the,
uh,
of the,
empire getting smaller.
It's really a,
um,
uh,
a radical crisis and an ongoing crisis with the appearance of many enemies and
the radical shrinking of the borders of this empire.
So,
um,
again,
look at the empire in five 65.
It's making a good attempt at Justinian's death to mimic the Roman Empire at the
beginning of our course,
at its height in the third century,
it doesn't have Northwestern Europe,
but it has most of the Mediterranean.
And to the degree that the Roman empire was,
as we with fatiguing repetition have said,
a Mediterranean centered empire.
This empire of Justinian's,
uh,
does a good job of restoring that Mediterranean orientation.
If you look at the second map,
um,
during this period of what,
uh,
the author of this book that I took the map from Howden h a l d o n calls the
process of devastation,
you can see how much has been lost.
Uh,
the,
uh,
empire at this point consists mostly of Anatolia,
a little bit of Italy,
a few islands,
uh,
even the Balkans is mostly occupied by Slavs and Bulger's
there then follows a period of reconstruction of the stabilization of borders of
taking back some lands in the Balkans and in Anatolia from,
uh,
the Arabs in Anatolia and from various groups in the Balkans.
This is also the period of the icon of plastic and emperors.
And then finally,
uh,
a,
an expansion of the Byzantine Empire.
The golden age of the Byzantine Empire is this period after the settlement of
iconoclasm and eight 43 until the appearance of a new enemy,
the Seljuk Turks who won a devastating victory and 10 71 and begin a process of
uh,
what ultimately,
but in this case ultimately means a 350 years.
What ultimately would be the final crisis for the Byzantine Empire,
which would be extinguished by the Turks in 1453.
So if you look at map number three,
the Byzantine Empire around the year 1000,
um,
ignore Bulgaria for the time being.
That is a separate kingdom.
And we're going to talk about it soon.
Uh,
this is a compact empire compared to that of Justinian.
It is not in control of the Mediterranean.
It has two bases,
really,
the Balkans and Asia minor,
and it has a little bit of territory in Italy still.
Uh,
but,
uh,
this empire made logistics sense,
was never easy to keep together.
Nevertheless,
it was stable,
uh,
had enough money for its substantial military expenses and even to create a kind
of cultural efflorescence.
So here we have a story not merely of survival,
but of survival adaptation and expansion.
And that's what I want to discuss with you today of the reason we're doing this
is because this is part of early medieval history.
We've talked about the legacy of the Roman empire,
a three part kind of legacy in our formulation on Wednesday,
we'll start talking again about Europe,
northern Europe,
and the degree to which Charlemagne in particular,
uh,
is a self conscious heir to the Roman Empire.
He revives the title of Roman Emperor.
In the case of the east,
these people have never abandoned the title of Roman Emperor.
And indeed as a key thing about the Byzantine crisis in contrast to the crisis
of the West is that the empire never falls.
It is never destroyed,
but it does undergo many of the same crises and consequences of the crises that
the West did in the fifth century.
I said last time that to some extent,
uh,
while we don't like the term dark ages,
um,
uh,
certainly,
after the collapse of the western Roman Empire in the fifth century,
Europe enters into a period of radical materials simplification.
That is to say it is more rural,
there's less commerce.
It is politically more decentralized.
It is militarized
and its culture is the preserve of a relatively small group of clergy.
Yes,
a lot of the same things happen in the Byzantine Empire in the seventh and
eighth centuries.
This is a kind of dark age for Byzantium.
We don't have a lot of written sources.
For example,
there seems to be an almost complete desertion of the ancient cities and with
the exception of Constantinople itself and one or two others,
same kind of ruralization of society.
It is a militarized society,
although as we'll see with more central governmental role.
But it is a society built around warfare
and it is a society in which culture is also somewhat restricted.
Uh,
the libraries don't get destroyed exactly.
But they certainly don't get a whole lot of use,
at least in terms of things that we can understand or fall.
Wow.
And the Byzantine Empire faced an awful lot of enemies.
The history of Byzantium is to some extent the history of emperors.
You never heard of writers,
you never heard of a lot of really need art
heresies that you may have never heard of before,
but you have to learn anyway.
Um,
and uh,
invaders,
some of whom you've heard of,
some of whom not.
But Harris season invaders are really the story.
Uh,
so I didn't make this history,
but,
um,
it is very important.
And actually,
uh,
I think Harris,
these are kind of neat.
Uh,
although who am I to say since I went into this for a living,
so I must've liked them.
The most dramatic enemy of Byzantium in this period is the caliphate,
the Arab empire of Islam.
And so in terms of the shocks and crises of this period of contraction after
Justinian the rise of Islam,
and in particular the two dramatic sieges of Constantinople in six 74 were a
naval battle,
finally defeated the Arabs,
uh,
um,
forces and the siege of seven 17,
six 74,
seven 17 to sieges of Constantinople by the caliphate.
So what was the problem of imperial overreach?
Just to take this back to its origin?
Justinian in particular,
as we said,
was focused on the conquest of the western Roman Empire,
which he saw,
of course not as a conquest,
but as a reconquest,
a restoration of territory's taken unjustly by barbarian rulers,
which he was determined to take back.
He already had one enemy,
however,
and that was Persia on the eastern front.
This is nothing new.
We started the course with the,
uh,
Ryan and Danube frontier as one a front and the Persian frontier in the east as
another.
The only difference is now the Ryan and Daniel Frontier has been breached.
Justinian pacified the Persians,
paid them off,
made a treaty with them in order to have a free hand to undertake the conquests
in the west.
In retrospect,
you know,
with,
uh,
um,
the historians ability to quarterback,
uh,
after the game,
the,
um,
lack of attention to purse was a mistake.
The Persians in fact,
invaded despite this peace treaty,
uh,
in the,
five forties,
uh,
the Italian campaign didn't go well.
Uh,
things were patched up.
Justinian died in peace,
but his empire was quite a fragile.
In addition to everything else,
there's a plague and five 41,
five 42,
that kills a very large proportion of the population.
And as I said,
after just Indians death in five 68,
the lombards invade Italy.
And beginning just a few years later in the five seventies,
we start to have another force that's a little more difficult to describe,
just,
uh,
in the manner of the convenient term.
Lombard's I mean,
we don't really know what Lombard's means.
We don't really know who these people are.
I mean,
we know a little bit about them,
but,
uh,
you know,
it's a pseudo ethnic name.
We don't really know how people identified themselves,
but it becomes even more confusing with the groups that invaded the Balkans.
The conventional way of describing these is that the leaders were a group called
the a vars and their subordinates.
They are sort of cast of thousands.
They're slave armies,
whatever you want to call them,
more slobs.
The vars are a Turkic or Mongo.
People of the Slavs are Indo European Slavs.
Uh,
this is to some extent how the Slavs get into the Balkans.
how this worked,
uh,
relations between the Slavs and the virus is not completely clear,
but we certainly know that they took over much of the Balkans,
including Greece.
Greece in this case has to be considered part of the Balkans.
So the south eastern corner of Europe,
modern Greece,
Bulgaria,
European,
Turkey,
Albania,
Croatia,
Serbia costs of Oh um,
Bosnia Herzegovina.
Um,
all of these countries are at heartland of the Byzantine Empire in its post,
just in the antic form,
but,
uh,
now invaded by a vars and Slavs beginning and five 70.
The Emperor Maurice was murdered by his troops in six oh two campaigning in the
Balkans against the a vars and the Slavs.
He was succeeded by a cruel but hapless general named focus,
who's disastrous rule has emperor involve not only the uprising or invasion of a
vars and Slavs and the Balkans,
but a,
uh,
Persian invasion in the east
focus was overthrown in six,
10.
The Persians a virus and Slavs allied against Constantinople.
And in six 26,
the city was besieged from both sides.
The Persians camped out across the Bosphorus in Asiatic,
the end of Asiatic Turkey and the AE vars and the Slavs camped out outside of
the great theodosian walls of the city.
Uh,
uh,
that we're on its land side.
It's western side.
The fact that the city managed to overcome this was attributed to various
miracles and saints and particularly the protection of the Virgin Mary.
And it's very important in terms of the later history of iconoclasm to point out
that they had icons and all sorts of wonder working,
uh,
portrayals of powerful saints on the walls in order to protect the city.
And it worked.
Uh,
or at least certainly it looked like it worked.
the,
uh,
the invasions were foiled.
How did the Byzantine Empire fight?
How did it manage to withstand these invasions?
Um,
very briefly,
one factor is the strategic position of Constantinople.
A city extremely difficult to take by force.
Indeed,
it would not be taken by a flat out of salt until 1204 when western crusaders an
alliance of the Venetians and uh,
uh,
the Franks as they're called basically various western European groups,
um,
took Constantinople,
uh,
how they took Constantinople,
why they didn't go to Jerusalem,
which was the original plan and how they took a Christian city instead of the
Muslim held.
City of Jerusalem is a topic for the next semester,
but that is the first time that the walls were breached by force.
There is,
there are various successful sneak attacks.
So,
for example,
uh,
in hour period,
the emperor Justinian the second
had been deposed,
uh,
and,
um,
had his nose and tongues slit.
Uh,
this form of mutilation was to prevent him from coming back again,
was considered more humane to mutilate someone than to kill them.
But the mutilation was considered to be disabling.
You can't have an emperor with a,
you know,
whose knows is basically gone.
Um,
but they were wrong about him.
In fact,
he came back with a force of people from,
if you look at that,
I'm a third map Terrison the Crimean peninsula that's sticking out into the
Black Sea.
They besieged the city and he and some followers snuck in at a point where the
aqueduct,
uh,
one of the aqua ducks met the wall who's a little sort of space to,
to sneak in.
And,
uh,
they managed to,
um,
by a surprise attack and by acclimation of the noseless Emperor Justinian,
uh,
when the city for themselves.
Um,
so this is an example of a successful siege,
but not a flat out,
uh,
you know,
open a assault.
Now,
just an Ian rain had a reign of terror for another six or seven years after
seven oh five,
the date of the siege.
Um,
he was a very angry man and,
uh,
he got his revenge on as many people as possible,
including people who had nothing to do with his mutilation.
And he was eventually killed an awful lot of these emperors.
Dot.
Violent deaths.
Uh,
they're,
um,
they're tough guys,
but it's a fairly tough time.
So,
uh,
Persian,
a Var,
Slav,
siege of six 26,
the seeming victory of [inaudible] this over these forces.
And then it's virtual undoing by the Islamic conquest of much of the Byzantine
Empire member,
the conquest of Syria and the six thirties,
the capitulation of Alexandria in six 42.
We looked at all of these from the Muslim side very recently.
Meanwhile,
while Byzantium was busy losing,
it's a much of its empire in the east.
The Slavs were permanently settling in the Balkans and in Greece and they,
we're now joined by another invading people.
The Bulger's,
the boogers in it.
And that is the people who live in Bulgaria are a Slavic people.
But the original bull guards were a more Turkic people who formed a kind of what
was called connate.
That is a,
um,
uh,
state ruled by a military leader,
a con.
But here again,
uh,
who are the boogers ethnically?
How many of them have Slavic followers?
Um,
uh,
it's,
it's both very controversial.
That is the Bulger's hate the notion.
The modern Bulgarians hate the notion of being thought of as ancestrally Turks.
So when I'm saying is heresy,
uh,
in some quarters,
but these ethnic designations are not as meaningful or at least as stable as we
often tend to think they are.
Uh,
the Bulger's would intermarry with the Slavs and they would eventually convert
to orthodoxy,
but they would be a problem for Byzantium from the about 700 until just after a
thousand.
So how is this empire rebuilt?
It was rebuilt on the basis of control over the Balkans and Anatolia.
It was also rebuilt on the basis of reorganization of the army.
Obviously,
the position of Constantinople and its walls is not enough to assure a victory
in battle once you get away from Constantinople.
There are certain kinds of weapons that they had.
There's this mysterious one that I mentioned before called Greek fire,
which is certainly part of the victory of six 74.
The naval battle against the Caliphs.
Um,
uh,
the um,
okay.
Uh,
it's a project top burning,
some sort of burning substance that explodes on impact and as useful to burn
ships.
Um,
but um,
the army is reorganized and this is one of the key aspects of this period of
contraction and of reconstruction of crisis and of um,
recovery.
And we'll come to that in a moment.
During this era of crisis,
it should not be thought that they didn't have time for religious controversies
in the seventh century.
The big controversies continued to be those related to the natures of Christ.
Even though the territories that were Manasseh site had been taken by Islam,
or at least the most monopolies side territories,
there's still are controversies trying to compromise this question of does
Christ have one or two natures?
How if he has two natures,
are these two related rather than saying he has two natures,
the emperor's proposed to possible solutions.
Okay.
Christ is both God and a human,
but he's got one energy on our end.
Urge ASM or maybe he's both God and man,
but he's got
one will
Monteith elitism.
The emperors in the seventh century tried to impose Mano,
Fella Tism or tried to impose Monteith elitism and then prohibit discussion or
just prohibit discussion about it.
Uh,
the papacy was adamant in upholding the um,
uh,
two natures
and um,
uh,
two natures,
one person and this,
this,
this eventually won.
But a huge amount of energy was expended in this controversy.
And in the eighth and early ninth centuries,
um,
uh,
we then have iconoclasm which as we've spoken about is the prohibition on the
worship of icons.
Icons again,
are a form of religious art that remains characteristic of the eastern church.
And the difference between icons and other forms of religious art is that
they're portable.
You can carry them around and they,
um,
are non narrative.
They don't tell a story.
So an icon doesn't have,
you know,
a depiction of the annunciation or a depiction of events.
They don't come in series showing,
for example,
the life of a saint or the um,
uh,
life of the Virgin.
They are a single depiction.
Yeah.
The iconoclasts we're worried about this as a form of idolatry.
We're not sure where this concern came from.
Eh,
there is no evidence that it comes directly as a reaction to Islamic or Jewish
criticism.
Although of course Islam and Judaism patrol the frontier against idol worship or
image worship much more severely than does Christianity.
Okay.
It does seem to be a reaction to the crisis.
It does seem to be part of an effort to re make Byzantium into what I guess now
would be called a leaner,
more adroit responsive or that a obnoxious business word.
Now,
what robust a robust response to the crisis imposed by Islam.
Certainly it has something to do with that.
Okay.
But what it really shows us is the role of the emperor in religion.
The role of the secular ruler in the West is not as extensive.
Even as we will see soon under Charlemagne,
remember Clo tar and his attempts to dictate religious doctrine to Gregory of
tour.
Who scared though he is of Clo tar basically laughs at him
that shows a ruler who does not really have control at least over the doctrine
of his church.
Even if he's got a lot of control over the wealth of the church,
the western tradition would tend to separate out ruler of the state and Ruler of
doctrine.
The east less so.
This is partly just the way,
uh,
the patriarch of Constantinople is situated.
He's right next to the palace of the emperor and so can be intimidated by the
emperor.
It is in the tradition of the Orthodox Church that there is less resistance to
state authority.
I'm a part of the church.
More collaboration with state authority,
uh,
and um,
less controversy.
Vaneen this is the way it's normally taught is that the emperor functions kind
of like the pope in the West.
The emperor defines doctrine,
but actually however much difference is paid to the emperor and however much the
emperor tries to define doctrine,
the real story,
certainly four hour period is of the lack of success of the emperors.
The emperor's constantly come down on the wrong side or come up with compromises
or doctrines that don't work.
They propose what in a sense seems like a rational compromise over
monophysitism.
But theology doesn't work that way.
Just because you come up with a compromise doesn't mean everybody's going to
accept it.
In fact,
often compromises mean that nobody accepts it.
It's not,
you know,
like a negotiation over,
uh,
you know,
political trade offs.
This is,
uh,
a theological truth.
So the is then create their own theological position.
ICONOCLASM is very much an imperial demand.
And for time they succeed in imposing it.
They succeeded in imposing it for 120 years off and on.
Sometimes there'll be an emperor who is a moderate iconoclast,
but let's the icons come back.
Sometimes there's an emperor's,
a moderate icon.
Oh,
dual or a of file.
Um,
but the emperors,
Ethan in the East,
even where the emperor is so heavily involved in religion,
have limitations on their bill ability to define doctrines.
Nevertheless,
clearly they are the leaders of a besieged people who sees itself both as
Christians against,
uh,
pagans or Muslims,
or at least a infidels,
uh,
and as a,
um,
you know,
as a religious people and as a secular population.
So with all of these crises,
sieges,
uh,
invaders,
how did the empire survive?
We can see some of the plans of the emperors.
One plan was simply to get out of Constantinople and rebuild a kind of a western
empire based in the West.
So constants,
the second you'll remember I said in six 61 moved his capital to Syracuse in
Sicily,
a,
this was intended in part to guard the possessions in Italy and in part to hold
on to North Africa.
Contents was murdered in his bath.
In six 68,
the capital was moved back to Constantinople.
And within 30 years,
all of North Africa had been lost to the Arabs.
And you start to get the shape of the empire,
uh,
to resemble that of the map.
But we looked at last that have 1000 a Balkan Anatolian empire.
Okay.
Constance is very important though,
even though his plans come to not because it seems to be under his reign,
not exclusively,
but very much forwarded by him,
uh,
that two things develop that are crucial for Byzantine success.
One is the practice of deporting whole peoples and settling them on new lands.
This extremely brutal practice.
You can imagine what it's like at any time forces as practiced a considerable
amount.
For example,
in the former Soviet Union where you just tell people to get up and you're going
to move them 2000 miles away,
they're going to have better opportunities there now,
whatever.
But in the meantime,
some of them are going to starve.
Many of them are going to falter disease.
Uh,
this is a brutal kind of transporting of peoples manipulation of people's from
one area to another.
The People's manipulated.
In this case,
we're often Slavic prisoners or groups taken over as the empire expanded and
often sent to Anatolia to resettle lands that had been deserted in the Arab
invasions and now seized back from the errands.
This policy against what one might expect actually seems to work to the extent
that it does increase the population of these key frontier regions in the east
with militarized forces transported,
uh,
from the Balkans
related to this is the Organization of the army by locality instead of as a
mobile and very large force.
And this is related to the problems of paying the army.
As far back as the beginning of the course,
we said that a lot of imperial policy just as that it's just true of the state
today is dictated by the need to pay for trips.
The most expensive thing that most states,
including the United States does is maintain an army and use it
for a number of reasons.
This is just a very,
very expensive thing and clearly a necessary thing.
Something that is not easy to dispense with Diocletian's reforms.
Indeed,
the whole restructuring of the empire in the late third century and early fourth
century was oriented around increasing the size of the army,
basically doubling it and figuring out a tax regime to pay for it.
This no longer works in the post Justinian panic world.
In the crucial era here and beyond because the state does not have enough money
to pay these.
It does not have a tax base.
It cannot raise the money for a large army to operate in the Balkans and to
oppose the Arabs without the tax revenues from its richest province,
Egypt and from other very wealthy and important provinces such as Syria.
How then is it going to have an army at all?
To some extent it is going to do this by um,
creating local armies,
paid for not so much by money as by,
um,
kind that is to say grain leather,
uh,
weapons and things manufactured locally,
harvested locally,
and that stay locally.
This is the so called theme system.
And Wickham doesn't talk too much about it because historians are in the process
of drawing back from this.
This is one of those frustrating things about progress in history.
A lot of in history is the dismantling of convenient kinds of a formula.
So when I started teaching this,
the themes were everything.
I would've spent 60% of this lecture talking about the themes.
It's a situation and how it saved the Byzantine Empire,
the themes look like soldiers who are peasants.
In other words,
to some extent the,
uh,
the deal that's offered to these troops is,
we will give you land and we will allow you to keep most of what you produce
rather than paying it as tribute to a landlord.
But you've gotta be willing to fight for it and you've got to,
oh,
military service,
you've got to be ready for military service.
And indeed the land was often in places that were dangerous places that we're
liable to invasion.
This is to some extent true,
but um,
it's a little less of a kind of homestead act deal.
If you look at,
um,
map number three,
year 1000,
uh,
see the things that are in italic capital's like [inaudible] are many icon on a
telecon.
These are themes.
They are large agglomerations of provinces.
They are what might be called military provinces.
And as such,
they combine civilian and military rule.
The empire is now divided into military provinces.
Nothing terribly new about that.
Even though the shape and the size is different,
what's new is that rather than the revenue being raised in cash from taxes,
paid all over the empire and then transported to Constantinople and then
disbursed to mercenaries or two,
I'm standing armies,
the money that's raised in the obstacle on tends to stay in the up sick.
He,
these provinces tend to be responsible for their soldiers and for paying their
soldiers.
The state is very heavily involved.
This is not a militia in the sense of,
you know,
a bunch of trustee guys getting their muskets or whatever.
They used a off the wall.
This is not,
you know,
Paul revere or something like that,
but it is an army that is closer to the population and in which the male
population is largely involved in the military forces.
Uh,
another word that I don't particularly care for and it's monitoring use
stakeholder.
They're stakeholders in the sense that it makes a big difference to them.
They're not just civilians.
In this case,
this is then a militarization of society.
It is a new way of paying for things in an economy that is less,
uh,
productive of revenues at least of taxable revenues.
Uh,
and it is above all,
uh,
whatever its exact nature,
an innovation that works the basis for this expansion that takes place after
eight 43 and indeed for the stabilization of the frontiers that proceeds,
that is,
uh,
a reorganization of the army,
the theme system,
a reorganization of revenues,
uh,
and they kind of strategic plan to define the Byzantine Empire,
in a way that is ultimately about feasible and defensible.
Okay.
From seven 17 to eight 43 B empire recovers slowly.
We choose eight 43 because that's the end of the iconic class controversy.
The empire continued to have to fight on both fronts against the Arabs and the
Bulger's,
but it had a viable state of viable military structure and some capable,
uh,
emperors.
After eight 43,
we see a real rebirth and expansion from eight 43 to 1000 about the empire grew
by about one third.
Even though that map,
the third one for the year,
1000 doesn't seem very imposing.
If you take a look at it,
you'll see that it's frontiers with Islam are much more secure than they have
been before.
The empire extends eastward as far as Armenia for a long time,
a frontier province,
and it is a,
are on the borders of Syria.
It has the great city of Antioch.
Again,
it has all of Anatolia.
It has the islands of Cypress and creed,
which had been occupied by Islamic forces for years.
It has control over all of modern Greece and uh,
has held onto some possessions in Adelaide.
This is an era of great splendor ceremony.
The restoration of education and of learning.
The Bulger's will be defeated definitively by 10,
19.
Constantinople would be besieged by them twice,
can't have a century without a couple of seizures of Constantinople.
The opposites are defeated.
And the expansion of the Byzantine Empire,
as you see,
uh,
as far south as modern Lebanon and as far east as modern Armenia,
well,
historic Armenian,
this is a society that is still involved in religious controversy.
This is the,
uh,
in the ninth century with the,
Carolyn's ends.
There would be a controversy over the Holy Ghost in relation to the son and the
father,
the so called Philly Oakway controversy.
Okay.
But it is a world of great energy,
artistic,
cultural and actually religious.
Perhaps the most lasting and significant accomplishment of this era is the
conversion of the Slavs and the conversion of much of eastern Europe
conversion to what would become the Orthodox as opposed to Catholic form of
Christianity.
The official split between the Orthodox world and the Catholic world won't occur
until 10 54.
In 10 54,
the patriarch of Constantinople excommunicated the pope and the pope
excommunicated the patriarch of Constantinople.
I think they've taken it back,
but obviously the churches are not joined.
Um,
they have differences already,
however,
that are visible in the ninth and 10th centuries.
Um,
orthodoxy is less politically centralized,
okay?
If,
as we just said,
it's very dependent on the ruler.
If the ruler is different than the church has a sort of national identity.
Thus there is no pope in the Orthodox church.
The Bulgarian Orthodox Greek Orthodox Russian Orthodox are,
um,
uh,
essentially form a confederation under their own patriarchs.
They also have their own languages.
The Bible could be translated into vernacular and the liturgy was,
um,
not in one language necessarily.
So Slavonic,
uh,
the sort of ancestor of modern Slavic languages would be instituted as the
liturgy in many of these,
uh,
converted places.
Priests are allowed to marry in the Orthodox Church.
Uh,
there are just sort of questions of style.
For example,
the Orthodox Church,
even when it has admitted icons back,
does not have statues,
does not have three dimensional statues.
Where's the Catholic world?
Of course.
Does think of,
uh,
you know,
um,
uh,
Notredame of Paris,
and it's sculptural program or shark or the,
uh,
you know,
Michelangelo and Bernini Sacred Sculptures.
Uh,
this is partly because while icons are okay because they're two dimensional
statues were thought of as being too much,
like the idols denounced again and again by the Old Testament.
Um,
Greek Orthodox priests have beards,
a Catholic priests down.
They're different styles of worship.
In Orthodox churches,
you stand,
you don't,
there aren't seats.
Some of this is style.
Some of this is theology.
Some of this is just culture.
But of course,
this would remain,
which would be in the ninth century and remain a very strong difference.
So you can see that those countries converted by the Catholics have a Latin
liturgy and a Western or Latin or Roman orientation.
Poland is Catholic.
Russia on the other hand,
would be converted to a Byzantine Christianity.
Uh,
the division is clear and,
uh,
um,
unfortunately tragic in the former Yugoslavia,
Serbian and Croatian are almost the same language.
Serbian is written in Currituck,
Croatian in Roman,
the Croatians or Catholics,
the Serbians are Orthodox,
um,
their hatred for each other.
Uh,
and then of course the complication of having an Islamic people.
The Bosnians,
uh,
was,
um,
be background to the tragic Yugoslav civil war of the early 1,909 days.
So these religious boundaries,
which sort of correspond to ethnic boundaries,
even though those ethnic definitions are themselves invented to some extent,
these religious boundaries continued to be very meaningful and to define culture
in Europe.
The conversion of this world is then one of the most important events of the
renascent Byzantine Empire,
the coronation of the king of Russia,
King of Kevin Russia.
In nine 89 at chairperson on the Crimean Peninsula,
uh,
presided over by emissaries of the Byzantine Empire.
Emperor is one symbol of this,
the conversion of the bulk.
Ours,
the conversion of,
uh,
many of the peoples of the Balkans.
And indeed there is a kind of aftermath of Byzantine civilization.
The closest heir to the eastern Roman empire is the Russian empire.
They'll look of orthodox worship,
the look of the Russian churches,
uh,
the icons,
the gold,
the imperial style,
um,
is,
uh,
very closely related self-consciously to the model established by the Byzantine
emperors.
Indeed,
in the 16th century after the fall of Constantinople,
uh,
Russian,
monks claimed that there had been three rounds.
The roam of the West,
the original 100 fallen in the fifth century.
The great eastern Rome bat of Constantinople had fallen in the 15th.
And the third realm was Moscow.
Um,
I don't think that outside of the Russian orbit,
most people think of Bosco as the third Rome for a number of reasons,
uh,
whatever its power and its own form of splendor.
But the degree to which Russia in its history is the heir to the world that we
have briefly described,
uh,
cannot be denied even if to some extent it is a self formed or self conscious
manifestation.
Moving from Byzantium on Wednesday,
we will come back to friendly old Frank Kia and discuss the rise and
efflorescence of the Carolingian.
Thanks.